Oh boys yes dad time to get to work
little man let's build us another
seamoth and don't blow this one up this
time but that was your drunken fault
shut up don't tell me who to drink I'll
drink whatever I want whatever I won't
is it done yet Thank You Geoffrey Billy
samurais and Marshall you're my babies
in a love yeah hello everybody captain
markiplier here back with another
episode of Nauticus so the modification
station wasn't what I thought it was and
I blew up my seamoth so frankly I'm
pretty much at no progress made over the
entirety of the last three episodes but
that being said I have devised a plan of
what I'm gonna be doing in the next few
because it's been a little bit of
frankly a silliness Cup to this point so
there's more stuff that I need to do but
that requires me to go down into the
depths which I'm pretty sure means that
I need to find a way to either get my
seemeth better or bring more air tanks
slash storage cube crap slash other
stuff that I need so what I'm gonna be
doing is let me think about that
okay so I've decided what this episode
is gonna be about this episode is about
exploration and I mean exploration
beyond anything that I've seen before
and that requires a journey so the
journey I'm gonna take is gonna take me
so far out to sea away from the ship and
just kind of directly into the abyss
because I want to see what the limits of
this game are if I know the exact scope
of what I'm doing then I'll have a
better idea of how to you know give you
guys something that you want to see as
opposed to you guys obviously telling me
what you want to see but also I
personally want to know just how far
does this game go just how far can I go
and what new crazy things are there out
there for me to see so with that being
said I'm gonna go prepare a few things
I'm gonna get some water and some food
to stock me up on the way out there I
think I'm just gonna go and
hey frankly I don't know how
this is gonna be but it could end up in
my death it could end up in my
excitement I could have lots of fun or I
could I'm probably gonna die but that's
besides the point because I got some
water and a first aid kit and a brand
new CMOS with lots of energy it's pitch
black at night what could go wrong let's
get to it
and why does the music have to be so
dramatic like Patti it's not like I mean
[ __ ] came it off here oh good I can see
some sort of a landmark in the distance
oh good the whole environment is shaping
and shifting as I'm wandering through oh
good there's weird brain coral type
devices that I'm seeing I guess I could
narrate this a David Attenborough style
as you can see in the ocean there's
Justin oh my god what is that oh god
what is that why oh gosh gosh Oh what is
that
oh god what is that oh it's got like a
brain mesh of nerve stems oh what is
that
what are you where am I seriously where
the hell did I go man God there's some
like green glowy gah Buell's
is that blood oil okay I'll collect some
samples why not warts deep shroom I
don't know what a deep shroom does I
don't think I want to know what a deep
shroom does can I like cut these things
well it's doing something to it it's
probably none too happy about that
because I imagine it has a brain of its
own and the ability to understand what
is that I don't
sorry okay I'm on my way Jesus so weird
okay I knew that I was gonna see
something new I just didn't know that I
was gonna see something new so quickly
okay so basically I need to find a way
to get down deeper than I've ever gone
before because there's can we not could
we have a fun time
could we have happy fun times instead of
mmm maniacal music just scare the two
knees off of me man I've no goddamn idea
where I'm going
hmm-hmm-hmm you know like you that mean
you like you that at all okay so so geez
didn't even know that sorry didn't mean
to goddamn so what I need to do God
there's just a curve voss oh this is an
immense crevasse Oh so weird
oh so weird okay back to the little bit
of normalcy but still a little bizarre
mmm
let me just make sure that I'm still in
the area of probably like silver and
copper oh geez yeah okay nothing too
amazing over here don't get off okay all
right didn't mean to thunk into you like
that apparently any impact will damage
it what are those things
oh man it's so pretty but so scary I
don't even know if it's still night or
if it's just the fact that I'm out so
far then maybe the son got scared of
this area and I should have a reason to
be afraid I should have so many reasons
to be afraid the ocean is terrifying
everybody never go into the ocean
there's a reason why we don't know about
the ocean because known as brave off to
go down there oh man and everyone who
did go down there who's like that scary
they died immediately they died of death
poisoning and all the horrible things
associated with it what does it want me
to do with that cave do I need the
bigger
I need the bigger one don't I oh I need
the bigger submarine let's see moth
ain't gonna cut it
I know what I need to do to be able to
get that but I don't have to go through
all the material handling I mean it
wouldn't take that long and punched I
could do that in between this in the
next episode but god damn oh it's so
scary I think I'm cycling back around
and I did not mean to so terrifying oh
hey how's it goin there buddy
ah you undulate weirdly when you're
making noises and I none too like it I
wonder if there's any way to make like I
know that said like propulsion gun or
something like that
[Music]
you cool terraform I can find out what
the god damn it that hurt I'm fine
though I can deal with it
ow you but it's not too bad
cool terraformer well that that earned
me some music I suppose so now I can
find out what the hell the terraformer
does and maybe in the meantime I can
figure out if I have enough material to
be able to make the bigger ship you know
actually that's what I'm gonna do in
this episode I did a little bit of
exploring you get to see a little bit
beyond the borders of my world but now I
need to make the hello rocks that broke
my shell Oh more rocks that broke hello
more rocks that broke my ship you're
freakin weirdos stop of you freakin
terrifying beasts so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna get the materials required
to build the better submarine and
probably that is gonna allow me to go
deeper into the ocean but first that
requires going into that deep cave and
finding even more lithium which
certainly was fun crazy too cuz I don't
do that spinning not spinning is now not
cool not cool bruh oh so not cool
that's sorry
oh god sorry Louis sorry about dit Oh
what there's little buggers here too the
violent buggers I got to find an area
where they're not farming I'll be back
guys unless something terrifying happens
you'll see it oh whoa whoa whoa whoa Oh
Oh God oh that's my fin charger working
not yes it's going a little crazy I'll
just replace a battery thank you nope I
guess I won't oh god that's not good oh
this is not what I wanted
Oh everything's gone wrong I want to go
home
it's so weird all right that'll have to
do for now
that's all I can hold well I haven't
been here in a while
owner if any horrible monstrosity has
taken up residence from the Blood Moon
hello
anybody in here to murder me still seems
nice and smoky just as I left it all
right so enameled guess talker tooth how
am I gonna fight a stalker I need I need
five of those god damn it what's us so
this tactic was just just horrifying it
says that I should tease the stalker
with my seamoth and get them to bite it
and they'll drop something those drop a
tooth in the attack I can also feed them
peeper fish hey buddy hey you is fat
hello did you jump
donk did you drop a tooth how can I tell
your teeth are tiny how would I be able
to know hey you hey hey come here we're
gonna do this on the seafloor come here
bite me [ __ ] hey your mom was a fish
how dare you murdered [ __ ] door Hodor
okay they drop a tooth how how would I
even know how it how would I know at all
how in the war this is a bunch of bull
oh they're they're [ __ ] with me how
who okay you know what I'm gonna go the
peeper Fisher out because this is
impossible
all right I got me some peepers so if I
take these peepers and I deliver them
hand fed to these cannibalistic
douchebags after getting a little bit of
air thank you very much having a little
bit of shelter thank you very much
douche where'd they go where'd my buddy
boos go where my friend oh there they
are
so if I go over here and I feed them hey
buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey who wants
peeper I'm probably gonna die from the
ball God here we go laughs haha oh did
you like that are we is we friends now
nuh nuh nuh mum okay it said it was old
age whoa goddamnit how do i Oh God what
the hell was that oh I see oh I see
teeth ooh I see a whole bunch of teeth
oh I'm going for it screw it I'm going
for it take a fish take a [ __ ] take
Bevers oh god I see teeth oh I can't
believe it
whoa I can't believe it whoa I can't
believe it oh I can't believe it
whoa Nellie yeah
all right so I think that's four I'm
pretty sure that was four god that was
awful huh man hey all right now I got
what we needed
okay we're good everybody we're good now
I get it now because enameled glass
tooth teeth have an Amal
ha ha ha ha man the lot skin this game
is a little funky but I got it that's
scary but I got it ok so I got 5
plastiline gets 5 enamel glass so all I
need is to save goddammit and then I
need lubricant and advanced wiring kit
the advanced wiring kit needed gold and
a computer chip it's super super easy
ok so now I just need to make the
computer chip which needs silver or gold
and I think table coral not common
quarrel which don't ask me why Oh quartz
bamboozle okay I got everything I need
this is it
oh oh I'm gonna ride my CMOS over to
Geoffrey Billy samurais and Marshall and
give them a new command oh the sun is
shining
[ __ ] foosh OH
oh god I could get some serious air with
that hot damn that's not bad okay wake
up boys wake up time to get to work we
got a cyclops to build three to go whoa
oh my god whoa oh my god oh it's
beautiful
holy crap oh look at that
oh look at that
god kersploosh indeed oh good job boys
god damn good job Jeffrey Billy samurais
and Marshall you are just a delight huh
whoosh oh it's bigger than my bass I
didn't expect it to be that big holy
damn oh my god oh my god oh who is that
forget Karen oh I'm gonna call you Linds
Linds Bo oh [ __ ]
damn it I'm gonna call you Lyla Lyla
yeah like that
holy crap now if only I had friends oh
look at this oh my god no see I can
bring my baby with me oh I'm gonna bring
hang on I got to bring my uh I got to
bring my seamoth oh that's I didn't know
I could bring my seamoth with me that is
so cool
oh hey Karen how's it going have you met
Lila
have you met my delightful Lila I call
her Delilah oh my god is the healing
[Music]
[Laughter]
where's this go it just goes back to
begin OOP oh oh look at all the dew
daddy's submarine name I get to name it
oh this is so hard ah I get to color it
too oh okay yeah it's gotta be good I'm
a cop I'm a collar [ __ ] I'm full [ __ ]
[ __ ] the ocean please perfect perfectly
my submarines go [ __ ] the ocean oh man
oh look at you I'm gonna make you or
blue blue like my hair and then orange
cuz blue orange contrast is a thing oh
my god oh yes please oh it's so
cumbersome all but it's a mobile base oh
[ __ ] you Sancho look at me look at me
all right
goddamn that is so cool oh that's so
cool that is soaked does it have like
can I make a fabrication Bay in here can
I do that
oh that's so cool it's so cool oh it's
so cool oh man I need to put solar
panels on this business ah that's so
cool okay I'm done with this episode
there's so much more to do now oh this
is so cool so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what I
should do with my brand-new ship I'm a
smash a champagne bottle it to Kristen
[ __ ] the ocean the USS [ __ ] the ocean on
to the ocean blue
oh it's so pretty so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always in
the next video darn it a hospital ah
[Music]
damn it
spit